The president and the hairbrained people around
him are increasingly fear mongering around
the stock market, saying if Biden wins in
November.
Say goodbye to your four or one case.
Here's actually a tweet from Donald Trump
yesterday where he said, quote, If you want
your Forell one KS and stocks, which are getting
close to an all time high, Nasdaq is already
there to disintegrate and disappear.
Vote for the radical left, do nothing Democrats
and corrupt Joe Biden.
Massive tax hikes.
They will make you very poor fast.
Now, I already dealt yesterday with how the
overwhelming majority of Joe Biden's tax increases
go to the top one percent.
So I don't want to get derailed here.
But remember my segment about how populist
rhetoric can be used to bamboozle people?
Trump ran with populist rhetoric.
He's for the middle class and he's against
all the oppressive factors that are repressing
the middle class.
Joe Biden is going to raise taxes on the very
rich on the top one percent and Trump populist.
Trump is now campaigning against it and scaring
people about it.
Doesn't sound very populist to me, does it,
anyway?
That's not what I want to deal with today.
I want to look at this claim.
Biden would be bad for the stock market from
a few different angles.
Now, the first is just a reminder.
Again, they are lying in the sense that the
stock market does better under Democratic
presidents.
I will get to that data in a moment.
But the other side of this that I think is
always important to repeat when something
like this comes up is that the Trump administration
continues to say or believe or claim or pretend
that you can measure how well an economy is
doing by looking at the stock market.
And you can't.
So before we even get into the numbers of
Democrats versus Republicans on the stock
market.
Let me remind you, stock market performance
does not tell you how well the economy is
doing.
Stocks are disproportionately owned by the
wealthy and by big corporations.
The more we learn about how do we evaluate
how well or poorly an economy is doing.
We understand that the stock market is a component,
but it is merely one of many components we
should be looking at.
We must look at the employment rate and unemployment
rate.
We have to look at wage growth.
We have to look at the quality of jobs.
We must look at.
Inflation and inequality.
And really, you want to look at quality of
life factors as well.
What is life expectancy, educational factors?
Where is literacy?
Right.
There are so many ways to figure out, like,
how is a country doing?
A big picture.
But let's for a second grant them that there
isn't empirical reality.
Stock markets either do better under Democratic
presidential administrations or Republican
presidential administrations.
We can measure it.
We can know this.
There are a whole bunch of different ways
to do it.
So you've got to make some decisions.
Like I'll give you some examples.
Do you would just stock market for performance
for inflation or not?
When comparing Democratic and Republican performance,
do you calculate returns with dividends reinvested
or not?
OK.
So there's like little tweaks in terms of
how you calculate it, no matter how you do
it.
Every serious analysis finds that stocks do
better under Democratic presidents than they
do under Republican presidents.
If you go back to 1929, on average, stocks
make about 10 percent a year during Democratic
presidencies and about two percent a year
during Republican presidencies.
That's one study from Forbes, another study
that looked only at the last forty five years
or so.
Found that the stock market return is about
14 percent per year under Democratic presidents,
10 percent per year under Republican presidents.
Now, the difficulty of these numbers is that
you can have sort of outlier years that can
skew the averages.
But from an empirical, historical perspective,
the stock market does better when there's
a Democrat in the White House instead of a
Republican.
But that's looking back.
OK, we then should analyze if we want to do
this thoroughly.
Would changing from Trump to Biden likely
raise the value of stock prices, lower the
value or or make no change whatsoever?
Very interesting.
New research from JP Morgan, which finds that
if you look at a Biden replacement of Trump,
it would either be neutral or slightly positive
in terms of stock prices.
And they also mention that adding a, quote,
diplomatic approach could be good for stocks
in that it would reduce volatility.
Now, this is funny because, you know, it's
JP Morgan.
They're trying to just make it a just the
facts analysis.
They don't want to be political.
Diplomatic approach is a polite term for Biden
will be more normal.
Right.
Biden will not constantly do crazy stuff.
Markets like normal markets like less volatility
at the other component.
That's more of an intangible.
If we think about the effect of Biden replacing
Trump on the stock market is a Biden presidency
would better deal with Corona virus.
And because Corona virus is really the major
drag on the economy right now.
There are additional benefits we would expect
to the economy from Joe Biden taking over
for Donald Trump.
We interestingly, we saw this under Bush,
Obama, the economy cratered under George W.
Bush.
Of course, 9/11 was a part of it, but certainly
going to war with a country that didn't attack
us, did not help, helped some defense stocks,
but it did not help the economy overall.
We saw the mortgage crisis devolve into the
2007 2008 recession.
And then Barack Obama came in, inaugurated
in January of 2009 and started to clean it
up.
Could have better cleaned it up for sure.
Didn't do everything right.
But that was the way it went.
We could end up with a very similar dynamic
under Trump.
Biden if Donald Trump is actually removed
in November and made a one term president,
not a guarantee, but something that could
happen, we could see a similar dynamic where
we see a proper economic recovery once again
under a Democratic president.
It remains to be seen.
But the point is the argument that Biden would
be worse for stocks than Trump, it doesn't
fit the historical realities of stock markets
under Democrats versus Republicans.
And it doesn't even pass the sniff test when
you think about replacing kooky, wild, wacky
Donald Trump with someone and Joe Biden, who
would be no progressive hero, but would certainly
bring back diplomacy and bring back some stability
and bring back some sanity.
Big day next Tuesday.
We've got two huge things going on next Tuesday.
It will be the third David Pakman show chess
tournament, 8:00 p.m. Eastern.
You can sign up now at David Pakman dot com
slash chess.
This is totally free.
I will be playing.
We had over 700 players during the June tournament.
Hope to do better than that.
Sign up for free at David Pakman dot com slash
chess.
Number two, we lost like 300 members in the
last week because we had a membership special
last year when those memberships came up for
renewal.
This year because of the virus, a lot of people
couldn't afford to renew.
So sadly, we had like our worst 72 hours of
membership ever.
So next Tuesday, the same day as the chess
tournament, we're going to do a one day membership
special.
If you want to be notified of it, just get
on my newsletter at David Pakman dot com.
We'll take a quick break and be back with
much more right after this.
The David Pakman Show David Pakman dot com.